j'ai 6 ans et je cours je cours je cours
je cours et un jour mon grand-père papy
Paul me dit ça ça c'est les mollets d'un
sportif
alors venons de n'importe qui d'autre
j'aurais pu ne pas le croire mais pas
venant de
alors cette phrase là elle est restée
dans mon esprit
et cette phrase là
plus tard
elle a sauvé ma vie
je fais 43 kg
j'ai 14 ans je suis anorexique
je suis anorexique parce que je suis
convaincu que je suis pas assez bien par
rapport aux autres alors c'est ma
manière à moi de disparaître
mon quotidien c'est pas le collège c'est
l'hôpital depuis plusieurs mois dans une
chambre de 3 mètres sur 3 avec
un lit
un bureau une chaise 4 murs qui
m'enferme pas de fenêtre pas cool
un jour il y a un mot qui est utilisé un
diagnostic qui est posé
bipolaire
alors ce qui est intéressant avec la
bipolarité c'est que les critères qui
étaient utilisés à l'époque ont évolué
depuis aujourd'hui je rentre plus dans
les cases on m'aurait trompé
en tout cas un jour ma mère arrive avec
une liste de personnalités qui ont fait
leur coming out par rapport à la
bipolarité elle me dit rends-toi compte
c'est la maladie des grands hommes
il y a Tom Waits
à l'époque je connais pas Bob Dylan
je connaissais un petit peu Eminem ça je
connaissais bien Catherine Zeta-Jones
Mel Gibson ouais mais il y a aussi
Roosevelt Churchill
et Robin Williams
Robin Williams
Robin Williams le héros de mon enfance
dans le film Peter Pan hook
j'ai un point commun avec Robin Williams
mais c'est le plus beau jour de ma vie
enfin
pour un type de 14 ans qui habite à
l'hôpital
tranquille
mais si j'ai un point commun avec Robin
Williams donc Peter Pan
mais je suis pas moins bien que les
autres en fait c'est comme si j'avais un
super pouvoir
à cet instant
me revient en mémoire un moment du film
donc dans le film hook Robin Williams
incarne Peter Pan et Peter et attabler à
table avec les enfants perdus ils ont
faim ils ont rien les assiettes sont
vides
et pour pouvoir les remplir ils doivent
utiliser leur imagination leur
imagination alors aujourd'hui le
thérapeute que je suis se marre encore
du rapprochement entre un anorexique et
une scène de bouffe pour changer de
point de vue
donc ma mère quelques instants plus tard
s'en va fin de la visite
et je reste seul
mais en vrai je suis pas seul parce que
moi
j'ai une idée
j'ai une idée mais j'ai pas assez
d'espace dans cet endroit qui m'enferme
alors j'ai 4 murs j'en choisis je prends
4 feuilles et je les scotch ensemble
pour m'en faire une fenêtre
au bout de quelques instants du coup je
me retrouve avec une fenêtre vide sur un
mur blanc mais moi ce que je veux c'est
voir au-delà de cette fenêtre et à cet
instant la phrase de mon grand-père me
revient les mollets de sportifs alors je
prends un stylo et je commence à écrire
des mots des fermes des verbes d'action
j'écris courir nager sortir
randonnée dribbler marqué
grimper
au bout de quelques instants je fais un
pas de recul
et je me retrouve avec une fenêtre
sur mes rêves en fait j'ai une chambre
avec vue sur mes rêves
je viens de créer un trompe l'oeil avec
mes rêves
je viens danser le trompe réalité
je fais
90 kg
j'ai des bleus sur tout le corps et des
coca au visage
j'ai 18 ans
je suis rugbyman
moi mes études
c'est le sport et ma passion c'est le
rugby j'adore ça j'adore ça la boue les
matchs les placages les copains les 3e
mi-temps
sauf que lors d'un match
un type me fait l'effet d'un mur
et lors d'un plaquage la douleur
m'indique tout de suite que quelque
chose de grave s'est passé
le rugby c'est fini
m'explique un chirurgien derrière son
grand bureau
il m'explique qu'il va falloir mettre du
métal par ci par là et moi pendant ce
temps là j'écoute pas vraiment je suis
ailleurs je suis ailleurs
je suis devant ma fenêtre sur mes rêves
et à cet instant il y a une petite voix
qui me dit eh regarde prends le mot tout
là-haut grimper oui grimper prends
celui-là les demandes lui si tu peux
grimper
si on veut faire
est-ce que je peux grimper
oui je vois pas d'inconvénients me
dit-il d'un air vraiment dubitatif
voyons la carrure du bonhomme qui
n'était pas du tout prêt à l'emploi
ok opérez moi
quelques semaines plus tard ça y est je
peux grimper
sauf que moi j'ai un problème
jamais grimper
moi l'escalade je connais pas moi mon
univers c'est l'horizontalité c'est la
boue la verticalité la hauteur je
connais pas et en plus de ça je découvre
un truc assez génial je découvre la peur
j'ai peur de tomber
alors que je suis jamais tombé
j'ai peur d'un truc qui m'est jamais
arrivé
mais moi je vais pas renoncer comme ça
alors à cette époque ma tante
anesthésiste pratiquait déjà l'hypnose
quotidiennement et assez naturellement
elle m'oriente vers cet outil je me
retrouve du coup dans un cabinet d'un
praticien en hypnose j'arrive je lui
explique ma vie mes problèmes l'anorexie
la bipolarité la peur l'épaule le rugby
le plaquage
il m'arrête il me dit OK
imaginez quelque chose si tout ça
pouvait changer ça donnerait quoi votre
vie
là mon cerveau s'arrête
et si tout ça n'était qu'un filtre
quelques minutes plus tard je sors et je
sens que quelque chose en moi a changé
parce que j'ai beaucoup plus d'envie que
de peur
alors je me mets à grimper
je fais quatre expéditions à travers le
monde et à côté de ça j'étudie l'hypnose
et j'en fais ma profession
assez naturellement je me retrouve à
travailler avec des sportifs
et à ce moment là j'ai une question qui
m'anime et qui m'anime encore
comment font-ils pour faire ce qu'ils
font
il y a des limites il y a des
contraintes il y a des records comment
font-ils pour tous les jours s'entraîner
pour battre ses limites repousser les
records
et aller vers de nouveaux sommets
et puis d'abord
d'où est-ce qu'elles viennent cette
limite contre lesquelles
il s'entraîne
impossible impossible le corps humain en
subirait des conséquences mortelles
c'est ce qu'on pensait
dans les années 50 à l'idée
de courir la distance du maïs 1609
mètres en moins de 4 minutes pourtant en
1954 Roger Lannister n'est pas mort non
il est rentré dans l'histoire du sport
international comme étant le premier
homme
à avoir couru cette distance en moins de
4 minutes par la suite il a même été
suivi par une centaine d'autres
surprenant aujourd'hui ils sont
1660 un peu plus même
avoir couru cette distance sous la
limite des 4 minutes et le record est à
3 minutes 43
comment c'est possible
effectivement l'histoire nous montre
nous prouve même que Bannister avait
raison mais avant qu'il y arrive qui
avait raison qui avait tort qui était
trompé
et surtout comment Bannister a fait pour
se libérer de la vérité des autres
alors oui c'est sûr
Lannister c'est un champion mais c'est
aussi valable pour les anonymes comme
vous et moi par exemple
Sarah court le marathon de Paris
ça y est elle arrive au mur du 30e
kilomètre en tout cas pour elle c'est
simplement le 30e kilomètre il y a
certains coureurs à côté qui commence à
peiner à ralentir certains s'arrêtent et
parmi eux
certains ne repartiront pas
pourquoi pas
elle pourquoi et tout simplement parce
que Sarah n'était pas au courant de
l'existence de ce mur du 30e kilomètre
imaginé
réaliser l'impossible les sportifs en
font leur quotidien
gravir les vraisses en moins de 7 jours
2 fois sans oxygène
qu'il y a une journée de la fée
descendre en apnée à moins 120 mètres
Arnaud Gérald vient de le faire cet été
l'impossible est un horizon pour
certains une cible accrochée à un rêve
mais pour d'autres c'est une barrière un
franchissable parfois même
avant d'avoir essayé
alors oui tout ça finalement c'est
qu'une question de point de vue
mais la réalité n'est qu'une question de
point de vue on le sait on l'oublie vite
la preuve un jour de chance pour un
trèfle à quatre feuilles c'est quand on
ne le trouve pas
je vous laisse un peu de temps pour
celle là
bon alors du coup sommes-nous
performants parce que nous en sommes
capables ou parce que nous pensons
l'être
imaginez vous commencez à faire du vélo
et puis vous tombez
ok à ce moment-là vous foutez dans le
vélo en disant je suis pas capable de
faire ça plus jamais je remonterai
dessus de toute façon c'est pas fait
pour moi
alors à cet instant
le monde se diviserait du coup en deux
catégories ceux qui ont fait du vélo du
premier coup
et ceux qui arriveront jamais
tenez comme ça
parmi vous qui a fait du vélo du premier
coup levez la main
sans les petits trous
il y en a moins là ouais en fait du coup
le monde se diviser en une seule
catégorie donc il se déviserait pas
et faire du vélo rentrerait dans les
capacités humainement impossibles à
acquérir
on est trompé on se limite
on se limite notre cerveau est capable
de nous faire croire à des scénarios
catastrophes qui ne verront jamais le
jour mais il est aussi capable
de garder en mémoire des choses des
souvenirs qui auraient pu rester
pourtant complètement anecdotique et
d'en tirer des vérités
parmi vous
combien entre vous ont peur d'échouer à
tel point que c'est difficile de prendre
des risques levez la main
oui
un peu plus là
et je vous raconte une histoire
mademoiselle a on va l'appeler
mademoiselle a elle a 5 ans
ça y est pour elle c'est le grand jour
elle fait comme elle faisait avec ses
petits trous sauf que cette fois-ci elle
vient de dire au revoir mentalement à
ces petits trous elle regarde droit
devant elle met les premiers coups de
et elle tombe et visiblement
c'est pas la seule à qui c'est arrivé
puis c'est pas la dernière non plus à
qui ça arrivera
à cet instant un de ses parents arrivent
la relève et lui dit
tu as pris trop de risques
tu viens de prendre un risque c'est
dangereux et tu viens de te faire mal il
faut pas prendre de risque comme ça
c'est pas bien c'est dangereux et cette
suggestions là
devient sa vérité
aussi étrange que ça paraisse
20 ans plus tard elle est grimpeuse
professionnelle
son job c'est de gravir un mur
d'escalade le plus vite possible il y a
un chronomètre à battre
une adversaire à côté elle porte les
couleurs de la France sur les
compétitions internationales
on appelle son nom
son travail il peut se résumer en deux
étapes la première c'est de mettre en
pratique une gestuelle parfaitement
travaillée à l'entraînement
et de prendre ce petit plus de risques
pour pour pouvoir gagner mais aussi qui
peut l'amener à échouer et à cet instant
la peur de prendre le risque grimpe sur
ses épaules
et elle va s'élever avec c'est cette
peur qui l'amène à venir dans mon
cabinet
elle m'explique qu'elle a tellement peur
d'échouer que sans doute elle a amené à
plus travailler que les autres et ça la
sans doute amener au niveau où elle est
mais aujourd'hui ça la limite et puis
elle m'explique aussi que ça la limite
dans plein d'autres domaines de sa vie
elle qui s'entraîne tous les jours
pour gagner
elle a peur de perdre
alors je l'accompagne sous hypnose
parce qu'aujourd'hui elle a rendez-vous
mais pas avec moi non non aujourd'hui
elle a rendez-vous avec une petite de 5
ans
qui est en train d'apprendre que
lorsqu'elle teste lorsqu'elle s'écoute
lorsqu'elle se fait confiance parce
qu'elle se fait plaisir c'est dangereux
elle va aller la voir
elle va s'en approcher elle va la
regarder
elle va la consoler parce qu'elle
s'englotte encore
elle va la prendre dans ses bras
et elle va la féliciter
la félicité de cette réécouter
elle va aussi lui dire qu'il est temps
de lâcher la peur pour pouvoir
s'élever devenir plus libre et elle va
aussi lui demander un peu de son audace
parce que 20 ans plus tard elle en a
bien besoin
pour grimper
quelques minutes plus tard les yeux ont
encore humides
elle me dit
l'escalade ça va aller
et puis
même au-delà
oui
se détromper
sur un mur du 30e kilomètre sur un mur
d'escalade dépasser une peur
ça va au-delà
alors le meilleur hypnotiseur du monde
c'est notre cerveau
et moi je ne suis qu'un humble
détrompeurs de limite des trompeurs de
cerveau
la vie est ainsi faite que nous sommes
imparfaits et nos imperfections sont
parfaitement faites nous sommes trompés
nous sommes trompés depuis Saint Thomas
qui disait je crois que ce que je vois
alors que c'est l'inverse si je vois que
ce que je crois et je crois ce que
j'imagine
peut-être que à l'école primaire nous
devrions avoir des cours d'imagination
et des cours de choix de nos croyances
parce que nous avons des croyances
aidantes et nous avons des croyances
limitantes qui viennent nous tromper
parce que le cerveau est capable de se
croire incapable mais qu'il est aussi
capable de se croire capable
d'ailleurs ne serait-il pas intéressant
d'imaginer que le cerveau pourrait être
incapable de se croire incapable
et
je vais vous proposer une petite
expérience
pour vous montrer à quel point nous
avons des murs
et comment les dépasser je vous propose
de vous mettre debout
et de vous décaler légèrement les uns
des autres
ce que vous allez faire c'est que vous
allez dans quelques instants pivoter
donc faut juste avoir suffisamment
d'espace pour
pour pouvoir le faire en toute sécurité
je vous propose un truc très simple
gardez les pieds au sol et tendez votre
bras droit
et ce que je vais vous proposer ça va
être de tourner sur vous-même en allant
le plus loin possible quand vous arrivez
à l'endroit où vous êtes le plus loin
possible vous pouvez pivoter maintenant
quand vous arrivez à l'endroit où vous
êtes le plus loin possible prenez un
point de repère avec votre pouce comme
si c'était une cible c'est votre mur
pivoter en allant loin loin prenez votre
point de repère et quand vous y êtes
revenez dans la position initiale
et maintenant
baisser le bras et fermer les yeux
et imaginez que vous refaites exactement
la même chose que ce que vous venez de
faire
réimaginer votre bras c'est votre bras
vous le connaissez
et puis imaginez que vous tournez de
nouveau jusqu'au moment où vous arrivez
mentalement
à l'endroit où vous êtes stoppé et puis
là
dépasser le
avec votre imagination
faites un tour complet
voire même allez soyons fous faites-en
un deuxième
et au moment où vous avez fait deux
tours ouvrez les yeux tendez le brin
droit et de nouveau avec la même
consigne allez le plus loin possible
[Applaudissements]
vous pouvez vous asseoir
alors qui
vient de franchir une limite
qui
a trompé qui
n'est-ce pas
que ce soit face à un mur d'hopital un
mur sur un marathon
un mur d'escalade ou n'importe quel
autre mur que la vie peut mettre sur
notre chemin nous avons des outils
l'art de tromper les cerveaux non
non
par contre nous pouvons tous devenir des
maîtres dans l'art du détrompage de
notre propre cerveau
nous pouvons tous choisir nos croyances
merci papy Paul et merci à vous pour
votre attention
[Applaudissements]